[Music]
the first modern humans that we know
have ever existed lived in africa and
they date to somewhere between 230 000
and 315 000 years ago so modern people
have been around in africa for a very
long time and then sometime around 80
000 years ago it looks like there's this
kind of big movement out of africa but
meantime on the continent of africa a
lot was happening too and that's when
you actually start to see the first
evidence that there was this really
widespread mingling and moving and in
terms of what we find archaeologically
this is when you get a real explosion in
the first art the first clothing the
first personal ornaments and most of
that happens first in africa and all of
that continues to kind of grow and
develop and change in the various parts
of africa but we don't know as much
about it as we do other regions because
there just hasn't been that much
research that's been done i first went
into the mount hora area in northern
malawi in 2016 because i wanted to see
what the potential would be to start a
new project in that region i knew
somebody had been excavating there in
1950 and that not a lot had happened
since then
so i was interested in the possibility
of actually being able to retrieve
ancient dna from this area and i did put
that in some proposals which my
colleagues reviewed and some of those
reviewed said that it wouldn't be
possible that ancient dna would not
preserve in these tropical environments
or that the site wouldn't actually be
very old and it's been rewarding to be
able to see that both of those things
are not true the site is actually quite
old it goes back into the last ice age
and some of the ancient dna that we've
been able to recover from there is some
of the oldest in africa
so a rock shelter is an area that's kind
of like an overhang and people will take
refuge under there and they might build
fires or bring home stuff that they've
hunted or whatever and so there's some
living activities that happen there but
they also will often choose those same
places as places of burial and what we
ended up discovering was all of the food
remains and the daily today activities
are recorded in these rock shelters but
we also found some human remains and
some of those human remains ended up
being some of the oldest that have been
found in the area and they are the
oldest to actually preserve ancient dna
in sub-saharan africa so what we did
with that was we combined it with a lot
of other new data with other teams that
had been working on other parts of that
part of africa eastern africa and we
found that when you kind of combine all
of these data together it really starts
to tell a big picture story about what
the ancestral population structure
looked like long ago it's interesting to
to think about the time scale because
the actual individuals that we found are
in they range in age from between about
16 000 years ago and 14 000 years ago at
the site that we discovered but there
are also other individuals in the study
and they ranged in time all the way up
to 2000 years ago every one of those
individuals can be thought of as the
product of all of their ancestors and
all of their ancestors ancestors what
we've been able to find
by doing this is that it looks like
people were really doing a lot of
widespread movement they're kind of
moving across the landscape they're
meeting their mating partners and then
of course the product is a new person
and
that ends up resulting in all of these
people who live in lots of different
places but they have
they have this kind of widespread
genetic signal and then this interesting
thing happens you start to notice that
genetically as well as in terms of the
material culture so this the stuff that
they're leaving behind it looks like
people are kind of sticking closer to
home
people were making ostrich eggshell
beads in similar ways across eastern and
southern africa and then after about 30
000 years ago there's divergence in the
styles that they make and the hypothesis
is that there was actually sort of a
barrier to the movement of people around
30 000 years ago
and so that's actually exactly the same
pattern that we see genetically where
there's evidence of widespread
movement and an actual contact between
people and then after about 30 or 20
thousand years ago right at the peak of
the last ice age those territories get
smaller and people start to behave much
more locally so we're actually seeing it
in both the dna and the and the
archaeological materials too this has
required expertise from researchers from
almost 20 different countries to do this
study and the individuals that were
presenting here the ancient individuals
come from recent archaeological
excavations such as the one i did but
also from
individuals that had been held in
museums and so some of my colleagues
were making their contributions through
sampling of those individuals and what
that means is that you have to go to
museums and you have to be able to find
what it is that you're looking for and
you need to be able to know that it is
in good condition it shows us how we can
connect the archaeological record to the
genetic record and that's one of the
things we've done in this paper that
we're really proud of is
having archaeologists co-write it with
geneticists side by side through the
whole thing
i think one of the biggest lessons here
is that we should always expect to be
surprised
[Music]
[Music]
you